welcome to this video i'm playing a
stickler just the stink of a gesture and
its own scandinavian transpose into a
cara con pan off the g6 line now this is
a popular now pop in the line no cannot
say that its own it's an ambitious line
this is maybe that the best the best
term to describe it Black is giving up
upon form ammonius development
interesting on does he want to play
Bishop d3 to see form maybe yeah didn't
really see what to do against it I
thought I have d6 anyway and then take
on b7 but dies wow you will have super
active pieces okay anyway night c4 yo
cool maybe Queen you on gravity it
doesn't really count yeah this is also a
pin
not the most convenient position ever I
do not sure this is helping yeah still
up really really uncomfortable pin b3 hi
just he just takes it
hmm Jim maybe I should just move it not
sure where I doesn't have a good square
g3 isn't isn't great small but do it
anyway it's just just a bit bit unstable
on YouTube my problem was what they have
what the heck was I thinking for one and
a half minute I came slightly weak back
rank but I don't see how we can use this
only need one or two moves to complete
development and then it Sam you're just
a pawn this should have form be three
maybe
now you can also play the bishop to see
three it's not terribly active but it's
it's it's solid keeps b2 and deform
protected
mmm I actually thought that Bishop f5
what would be good now okay hope I hope
it is because of b3f this night is very
unstable on d5 gap play be three next
move under what that Wow slick going
right into the pin
nitey force are also Google's now let's
let's play that for us I think this is
better even at first attacking on d6 and
I f-93 as well so be three and then 93
maybe
very tricky and now I can just take t6
or not this is a monster fork on on e HC
elastic resins this is one of the
biggest forks I ever saw I think c88
bee7bea 5 and this even d5 involved with
the bishop 103 wow this is funny yeah
well okay there should be five is since
11 but he's his in big troll anyway
maybe we move us or something I believe
that right at the beginning he certainly
had to head compensation at least
compensation maybe I'm wrong and of the
computer will help Ruby age back you
have the compass on +1 just just saying
our polym night see for the spectrum
possible and I thought just Queen a form
we have invented wants to take here yeah
yeah this this kind of line is probably
probably a good for black or okay for
black that same we've got the activity
can probably probably draw something or
draws on equal equal top position yeah
in the game it rather quickly turned
turned out to be very okay even this is
certainly playable position I mean
something like this just just for
example if you look at this he's got
good pieces this is it this is active I
mean this is close to compensation if
not compensation only here on here is
his in trouble because of this unstable
position be three will still maybe
better computer wants to go see one ham
this is probably really worth exactly
the palm that I have I mean I am a pawn
up and have a solid edge with this okay
well this is more that is solid yet so
the ultimate ultimate fork alright
thanks for watching